hallo leute ist wieder einmal war du
bekommst einer neuen folge wie schneck
und heute machen wir endlich endlich die
butterkuchen aus italien zu diesem video
hat die schon gemacht
da seht ihr mal wieder wie früher vogel
fängt den boden da ich ein sehr später
wurden bin hab ich das rezept immer
wieder nach hinten geschoben habe gesagt
ja ja das mache ich noch hier sind mir
nämlich seit über einem jahr im nacken
und wollte unbedingt dass ich die
butterkuchen aus ein kali mache ja und
dann dachte ich vor ein paar wochen
machte sie jetzt bestellte mal die
originalen snowboards um erstmal checken
was der oft richtig drin in das habe ich
dem schenkt dorfen kuchen gemacht und
dann habe ich gesehen dass wie die ruhr
in produkte gemacht hat und meine erste
reaktion war ungefähr so alles klar
alles klar ich dachte dass es jetzt
nicht mehr machen kann man mit leute
sonst in die kommentare schreiben
demnach müssen alle bistum kopierer oder
war es die firma aus zu kopieren
karli pro etage viel zu lange unter den
machen schätzen der russen gelitten
also liebe macht euch gefasst denn heute
gibt es den butterkuchen taiwanesischen
synchronsprecher anfragen einfach in die
kommentare ich kann auch ein mann
sprechen wenn es wir wecken jetzt den
bob andrews in uns und kümmern uns um
die recherche lasst die snowboards vor
ist es auch im richtigen reallife gibt
wollte ich die mal aufschneiden und
gucken was drin ist
versteh auch warum ihr die ganze zeit
gesagt dass ich das noch machen soll
weil das so lecker aussieht wenn sam da
so rein weist aber das wird zur seite
zieht aber wie schneiden kuchen humanis
claros wieder aus ihnen drin gibt einen
schokokuchen dann ein
weiße creme und einem marshmallow
schicht außenrum das ist halt das ganze
nur in blau menschen ist das für eine
creme damit es schmeckt wie eine
mischung aus marshmallow und zucker
glasur
wir probieren jetzt einfach mal oh mein
gott ich hatte schon ein bisschen angst
ist er so wie trinkt ist schmeckt also
ein künstlicher nach geschmack aber
überhaupt nicht obwohl die blau oder
pink schicht außen ist aus kokosnuss und
der coolness zwar dunkel aber schmeckt
jetzt nicht so intensiv schokolade um
diese runde form zu kriegen brauchen wir
auf jeden fall eine silikonform ist auch
gleich eine firma die brauchen wir auf
jeden fall und dann brauchen wir noch
marshmallows kann ich die auf gleich
bestellung marshmallows auf ja und
ansonsten müssen wir einfach nur ein
schokokuchen machen das werden wir noch
hinkriegen dass darauf freue ich mich
schon richtig das problem ist jetzt nur
die silikonform wird erst in einer woche
geliefert dann machen wir in einer woche
weiter für euch ist natürlich mal wieder
nur ein schnitt diese die konform ist
angekommen
eine woche später mit silikon und meine
marshmallows sind angekommen
silicon.de beginnen mit dem stück kuchen
und da habe ich mir ist ein ganz
einfaches rezept zusammengestellt denn
der kuchen in dem snowboard schmeckt
wird auch nicht wirklich großartig
schokoladig oder besonders das ist ganz
easy 250 gramm butter 50 gramm zucker 50
und ein einfaches berühren da reicht
auch wirklich ein handrührgerät ich
möchte ja auch dass die leute auch wenn
du angst vom backen zu haben ich war
auch ein profi als ich angefangen habe
und bin auch heute noch kein profi in
eine andere schüssel kommen jetzt schon
ein gramm mehl und da diese dinger ja
aus amerika kommen habe ich extra bei
kings oder gekauft und dafür nicht und
sie bewegt sich nichts
da ist man da drin achtung
das ist kaputt und dazu gibt es auch
eine story warum ich unbedingt dass hier
verwenden möchte
denn ich hatte ein englisch
wahlpflichtkurs ja ich hab n g streitig
gemacht in der realschule wo sie meine
realschüler und da haben wir mal nach
einem amerikanischen rezept muffins
gebacken und sie hat extra dass pekings
oder besorgt weil sie gesagt hat das ist
das beste für muffins und warum man in
der realschule im englischunterricht
machens markt halber teelöffel das ist
so wie viel zu viel höhere und damit es
einen schokokuchen wird cacau pulver ich
war shogun auch gerne mit echter
schokolade aber 20 gramm kakaopulver tun
braucht überall kann auch eine prise
salz drüber vielleicht cool aus und
damit glauben es den chorus play haben
habe ich jetzt 100 milliliter kokosmilch
und die kommt jetzt abwechselnd mit dem
mehl in die wir das rheinufer
[Musik]
ganz einfach und schnell könnt ihr so
einen tollen show gucken teig herstellen
backen ist möglich keine hexerei dafür
stehe ich mit meinem namen backofen
vorheizen wichtig auch kunden sich grad
umluft ich habe ja nie die ruß video
gesehen und sie hat einen schokokuchen
gemacht und dann kreise ausgestanzt ich
dachte mir nutze ich doch gleich muffin
förmchen die passen wollten immer sommer
sein
und nehmen wir unsere viel zu weichen
futter hasse buddha ich hasse so das
gefühl von butter auf den fingern ich
fasse fristlosen zu berühren wird darum
geht alles viel zu viel jetzt was ins
gesicht der spinde sind so entscheidet
ihr habt euch dieses rezept so lange
gewünscht also alkali habe ich
aufgeschaut nicht aber so viel wie zum
beispiel drake und george wo ja auch die
gleiche schauspielerin mitspielt und
sowie hannover
das habe ich auch geliebt und jetzt hat
eure beste vanessa noch einen tipp für
euch wenn ihr gute portion abfüllen
wollt dann benutzt einfach ein eis aber
wir brauchen ja nur ein bisschen teig
also das muss doch wirklich nicht zu
viel seien nur sohn mediation ich weiß
nicht warum aber sobald es kälter
draußen wird bekommt man lust zum back
ich auch schon gehört man die ganzen
weihnachtsmärkte in berlin aufmachen
weil es letztes jahr glaube ich nur
einmal geschafft habe weihnachtsmarkt zu
gehen und wenn es um weihnachten geht
dann bin ich auch so ein konsum oft
fahren stellen ja auch ein
weihnachtsmarkt gekauften über 1000 euro
schon heftig sondern auch das problem
meine eltern sind halt früher mit mir
nicht um weihnachtsmarkt gegangen weil
es halt so teuer waren wir hatten halt
nie geld diese extra die im leben dass
ich meine so wenn du gerade zu hause
sitzt und nicht zum weihnachtsmarkt
liegen kann für deine eltern auch
sparsame füchse sind oder nicht mehr
sich leisten können keine sorge
irgendwann kommst du in das alter wo du
selber über dein eigen
geld entscheiden kannst du bist so oft
zum weihnachtsmarkt gehen außer du hast
weihnachten in führung ich habe perfekt
eingestellt der historische sind wird
jetzt noch den teig zu
der soll ja groß und stark werden so
dass sie dort producer ist so leichte
these muffins kommen jetzt für ungefähr
20 minuten im ofen vielleicht noch ein
bisschen weniger weil sie ja wirklich
wenig teig ist und dann sehen wir uns
wieder wenn sie abgekühlt sind ich
gleich und hier sind sie unsere kleinen
kuhfladen in der winterzeit zu backen
ist auch sehr praktisch weil man es
draußen abkühlen lassen kann und es dann
einfach schneller geht manche sind ein
bisschen zu dünn geworden da habe ich
halt vergibt aber eigentlich sind sie so
genau perfekt und jetzt gibt's natürlich
an die füllungen die tolle marshmallow
creme füllung und man könnte sie selber
machen mit eiweiß und zucker in dem man
das aufschlägt und hat man aus sinne zu
kriege masse aber wir verwenden dafür
gute alte flucht creme dies einfach
perfekt weil sie genau die konsistenz
hat die wir brauchen die leute seien
auch wenn angst vom backen zu haben
deswegen will ich nicht zu kompliziert
machen zum befüllen müssen wir auf jeden
fall ein bisschen platz vorher machen
weil wir so reinschießen glaube ich dass
da nicht so viel creme rein
wir machen jetzt oben einfach ein loch
das passt perfekt und dann haben wir
noch ein bisschen gucken obendrauf
aber das ist doch perfekt so bereiten
wir jetzt unsere machen vor einfach ein
kleines loch rein
habt ihr schon den fantastische diesen
film gesehen weil es im kino bin
zwiegespalten ich mache natürlich ist
harry potter universum und alles drum
und dran
irgendwie
kriegt mich dieser film ich also der
zweite teil den erster der erste teil
war super so das wird jetzt sehr schwer
die angelegenheit okay genau so sieht
die füllung für die snowboards aus das
kommt schon darauf
doch der kam trotzdem ganz so pervers
und damit füllen wir das loch klingt
auch verwerten und wenn ihr die löcher
ganz ordentlich abgeschnitten habt dann
könnt ihr euch jetzt diesen etwas harzen
und deckel nehmen und den kleinen deckel
drauf machen so bleibt die creme liebe
es in sachen einfach gut funktioniere
die innereien könnt ihr dann einfach
speisen aufräumen müssen was so auf
jetzt kommen wir zum teil der ein
bisschen tricky ist und zwar müssen wir
marshmallows schmelzen zusammen mit
etwas butter davor fetten jetzt aber
ganz ordentlich unsere silikonform ein
den marshmallow ist sehr klickt finde
jetzt kokosfett passender weil deshalb
scopus geschmack hat so alles muss
fertig sein
auf die rennen da das komplette ding
einmal komplett in feste deckt zum glück
40 kokosfett nicht ganz so eklig den
fingern angebote nein bis jetzt doch
ganz einfach oder und jetzt kommt's
koenigsegg oder schmelzen eingangs
bisschen futter in tops also ein guter
teelöffel ja es reicht wenn die mutter
sich aufgelöst hat
da sind jetzt 150 gramm
das kann eine weile dauern aber wir sind
ja gedulden
oh mein gott dieser moment wird gleich
so aufregend tina schneider masse wird
nämlich sehr schnell wieder sehr fest
und deswegen müssen wir gleich die creme
rein machen und dann ganz schnell den
kugel rein drücken so probiert von mit
dem 1 ok und kuchen sein ist zeigt nach
oben siehst ja ok aufs herz immer wieder
gerne auf und ab dann wird es nämlich
nicht so schnell also und nummer zwei
sein um geld schon besser aus
[Musik]
er sieht für zwölf butterkuchen braucht
man 400 gramm nach schmeckt so und die
müssen jetzt natürlich abkühlen weil das
marshmallow wieder fest werden muss und
dass man jetzt einfach wieder draußen
bis gleich hallo leute es ist der
nächste tag denn ich habe gestern
verzweifelt versucht die marshmallows
aus ihrer form zu kriegen
vielleicht muss ich das über nacht damit
es richtig hart wird damit man es gut
raus blocken kann und es war noch viel
zu weit deswegen habe ich im gefrierfach
gelassen und jetzt kommt's versuch
nummer
ich hab da noch immer bei leader
geschaut wie sie das raus bekommen hat
und tatsächlich hat den schnitt gemacht
und ich gezeigt wie sie es raus gekürt
hat also muss ich nicht das war eine
gute idee zur jetzt können wir ein paar
herausstellten
und jetzt kommt die pinkel kokos schicht
ich habe die kokons schichten nicht hier
rein gemacht weil wenn das manchmal oder
reingekommen wäre hat wirklich sehr
einfach nur komplett verbunden werde ich
so um daraus geblieben
ich habe ganze zeit überlegt welche
pinke lebensmittelfarbe ich für das
einfärben verwenden kann damit die halt
auch nicht so klebrig werden weil wenn
man flüssige lebensmittelfarbe nimmt
dann glaube ich dass die vielleicht so
pappig werden und dass man so pinkl
lebens von edv dann immer an den händen
hat ich habe noch von dem kramberger
video sprühfarbe und zwar in pink die
werde ich jetzt in die schale rein
sprühen und dank kokosraspeln rein
machen weil wenn ich die kugel straße
wird zuerst ein machen würde und
rausspringen würde dann wieder wegfiel
haben partie an sprüht shapes mittelpaar
jetzt kokosraspeln rein und rühren diese
technik nenne ich tippen dafür nimmt
ihren marshmallow passt auf dass ihr
nicht dran kleben bleibt und jetzt folgt
ein kurs bei den originalen snowboards
hat man nicht gesehen dass sie
eigentlich weiße und dann die pink
chorus schichtung drauf liegt und sie
nicht von vornherein pink sind der wird
das schon mal toll aus aber mir gefällt
die pinkfarben noch nicht mir ist das
noch nicht genug
die sind so klebrig
und mein gott das ist so schön gerade
ich liebe es so gut geworden ich raste
aus
besser hätten sie einfach nicht werden
können
ich glaube ich bin verliebt die
butterkuchen aus diesem fertig jetzt ich
hätte wirklich nicht gedacht dass sie
mir so gut gelingt jetzt müssen sie nur
noch schmecken da ich den originalen
auch aufgeschnitten habe werde ich das
jetzt auch tun
seid ihr bereit die konsistenz perfekt
so gut aus die füllung ist wirklich
perfekt in der mitte durch den kleinen
deckel obendrauf ist es oft fest und
suzuki schaut euch das amt jetzt stellen
uns natürlich wieder deutlich zutage wie
schmecken die pinken butterkuchen aus
icarly endlich konnte ich es sagen guten
appetit
[Musik]
ungelogen sie schmecken genauso wie das
original sie haben wie bei sam diesen
shui weichen geilen geschmack perfekt
und wenn doch das video gefallen hat
dann zeigt es mit einem daumen nach oben
abonniert den kanal um keinen weiteren
video zu verpassen aktiviert die glocke
um kenne weiter ein video zu verpassen
stellt bei der glocke ein dass alle
benachrichtigungen ankommen und kennen
weil dann videos mehr zu verpassen
schreibt mir das kommentar was jetzt
nächstes kochen soll und grüße gehen
raus an die dir oh ich sag mal so polen
hat die weltmeisterschaft
ja ist dann ich werde jetzt buchen essen
gehen ich hoffe euch das wasser im mund
zusammengelaufen bisky